okay welcome back time for today's Bart
chart today we're looking at the price
of gold over the last five years
something big happened on Friday gold
raised its gains for the year now today
here on Monday gold at its lowest level
since August 2010 that was following
Friday's strong us jobs report prices by
the way are heading for their first
back-to-back annual loss since 200,000
don't forget prices fell 28% last year
why are prices falling investors
shunning gold as the US economy quickens
and the dollar gains don't forget the
Bloomberg dollar spot index has risen
for 7 weeks to a four-year High that's
on interest rate expectations in the
United States gold this year and you can
see it right there gold peaked this year
at 1383 it's dropped
14% since it peaked earlier this year in
March that's
$200 technically we had a death cross my
favorite technical term back on
September the 18th it's down 3% since
but the RSI the relative strength index
tells us gold is oversold any figure
below 30 is an oversold number it's at
24.4 what's the outlook for gold trading
at92 today what's the Outlook Goldman
Sachs reiterating its forecast for
prices to reach
1,50 in 12 months HSBC cut its outlook
for next year to 1175 to 1310 and sock
Jen says the metal will trade well below
$1,002 so gold erasing all its gains for
2014 and heading for its first
back-to-back loss since 2,000 keep an
eye on gold